[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره فلا رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه مارك ميلينا
الجيش الروسي يعاني بشده في اوكرانيا وانه
هناك احتمالا للحل السياسي وفق تعبيره
واكد ميلي ان تحرق قوات روسيا من كاملي
راديو اوكرانيا في القريب العاجل احتمال
مستبعد من جهاته قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الولايات المتحده لا تملي على الاوكرانيين
ما ينبغي عليهم فعله واكد ان وضع شبه
جزيره القرم امر يعود للقياده الاوكرانيه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني بلادي مرزالين سكينه
روسيا لم تقدم اي عرض لعقد مباحثات مع
اوكرانيا وجدد زلينسكي تماسكه بان الصاروخ
الذي سقط في الاراضي البولنديه الثلاثاء
لم يكنكرانيا من جهه اخرى قال جرين
الصاروخ الذي سقط في الاراضي البولنديه لم
يكن نوكرانيا
من جهته قبل الرئيس الامريكي
لا دليل على ان الصاروخ الذي سقط في
بولندا ليس اوكرانيا من ناحيته قبل الرئيس
البولندي
الصاروخ الذي سقط داخل حدود بلاده اطلق
بشكل مقصود واصفا الامر بانه حادث مؤسف
واضاف دودان الصاروخ الذي سقط في بولندا
اطلقته الدفاعاته الجويه الاوكرانيه على
الارجح
وبينما قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
روسيا من مسؤوليتها الاساسيه في الحرب حتى
الخارجيه الروسيه على عدم التورطي فيما
سمتها الاستفزازات القذره التي يرتكبها
تعرضت ناقله نفط لهجوم قبل سواحل عمان
وقالت القياده الامريكيه الوسطى ان الهجوم
تم بمسيره ايرانيه مفخخه
من الناقله مملوكه جزئيه لرجل اعمال
اسرائيلي
وبينما قال مسؤول عسكري امريكي
شاهد دانا مستشار الامن القومي
انه بمراجعه المعلومات فان ايران ربما
استخدمت مسيره الهجوم على الناقله واشار
الى ان الهجوم حريه الملاحات والتجاره
الدوليه
بتحقيق الحزب الجمهوريه الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي بعد حصوله على 200 و 218
مقعدا مقابل 200 وعشره للديمقراطيين في
انتظار حسم نتيجه المقاعد المتبقيه في
المجلس وهنا الرئيس الامريكي جو بعيدا
زعيم الاغلبيه في المجلس مؤكدا لاستعداده
للعمل مع اي طرفين لخدمه مصالح الشعب
الامريكي
ذكرت قوى الحريه والتغيير جناح المجلس
المركزي في السودان انها تعمل على توسل
الى اتفاق ايطاليا مع الجيش وكشف التحالف
قوى الحريه والتغييره
لانهاء ما سماه لانقلاب وتشكيل حكومه
المدنيه كامله هسه يوقعوا مع المكون
العسكري في السلطه في غضون عشره ايام كما
قالت قبل الحريه والتغيير ان الجيش وافق
عليه قائم مجلس الوزراء مدنيه بالكامل
ونقلت رويترز عن مصادر عسكريه السودانيه
قولها انها توصلت الى تفاهمات
الحريه والتغيير
هناك بنودقه
من ناحيته قلم وفوض الامم المتحده سامي
لحقوق الانسان فولكر ترك للجزيره ان لديه
تفاؤلا حذرا بشان امكانيه التواصل الى
توافق سياسي بين القوى المدنيه والسلطه
العسكريه في السودان واوضح ان دور المجتمع
الدولي هو الدعم اي اطار سياسي يتوافق
بشانه السوداني هو
اشكركم على متابعه المدرس طابت اوقاتكم
بكل خير
[موسيقى]